OK, I have a challenge for you today. Play
along. I want you to tell me whether what
I'm about to play for you is evidence of Donald
Trump lying, which he does often, or is it
evidence of Donald Trump glitching badly and
losing his memory of what he said just minutes
earlier during yesterday's corona virus White
House press briefing. So let's take a look
at the evidence. The new scapegoat for the
Trump administration around coronavirus is
the W H O the World Health Organization. We've
seen this develop and grow virally for lack
of a better term over the last 48 to 72 hours.
The Trump administration has realized, hey,
let's just constantly say that everything
bad that happened is the fault of the W.H.O..
Now, there's plenty of blame to go around.
I've been critical of the W.H.O., but the
Trump administration is going beyond that
and they are focusing their blame singularly
on the W.H.O.. While Trump continues to insist
he did everything perfectly. He did everything
quickly. He had the best response of any country.
Obviously not true. So let's get to the video.
Listen to what Trump says here very, very
clearly. He says, we are going to put a hold
on the money that we send to the W.H.O.. We
are going to do that very strongly. It's gonna
be a very powerful hold of the money. Listen
to Trump saying it coming out of his own mouth.
World Health Organization, because they really
are. They called it wrong. They call it wrong.
They really they missed the call. They could
have called it months earlier. They would
have known and they should have known and
they probably did. So we'll be looking into
that very carefully. And we're gonna put a
hold on money spent to the W. H0, we're going
to put a very powerful hold on it.
Okay. So just so we're really clear here,
this is just the sentence where Trump says
we are holding the money from the W.H.O.,
we are not sending the money.
And we're going to put a hold on money spent
to the W h-o. We're going to put a very powerful
hold on it.
So we're all on the same page. Trump says
we're putting a very powerful hold on the
money to the W.H.O.. A few minutes go by.
A reporter says, you know, we're in the middle
of a pandemic. Is this really a good time
to stop sending money to the W.H.O.? And Trump
says a hold. Who said anything about a hold?
I never said that. This is minutes later.
Ladies and gentlemen, take a listen.
So it is the time to freeze funding to the
W.H.O. during a pandemic.
You know, I mean, I'm not saying I'm going
to do it, but going to look at it. So we give
a tremendous noid. And I said, we're going
to look at it. We're going to investigate
it. We're going to look at it, but we will
look at ending funding. Yes. Because you know
what? They called it wrong. And if you look
back over the years, even there very much,
everything seems to be very biased toward
China.
I never said that. And reporters incredulous
start yelling. Yes, you did. And he did. One
more time. Here is what Donald Trump said
just minutes earlier.
And we're going to put a hold on money spent
to the W h-o. We're going to put a very powerful
hold on it.
And then minutes later, Donald Trump denying
that he ever said it.
So is the time to freeze funding to the W.H.O.
during a pandemic? Maybe.
I mean, I'm not saying I'm going to do it,
but we'll have to look at it. He did say we
give a tremendous noid. And I said, we're
going to look at it. We got to investigate
it. We're going to look at it.
So you all know what my question is, is this
evidence that Donald Trump's brain function
is so poor that he really has no recollection
that minutes earlier he said we're putting
a very powerful hold on the money or is Trump
simply lying? Is he trying to rewrite history
in real time? What explains this? I want you
to let me know your thoughts. I'm on Twitter
at David Pakman. Lying memory glitch. Something
else? I don't know the answer. You let me
know.